[Music]
all right
hello and welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy to
buying practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life hi I'm Dan Hayes
and I'm joined by my co-host Dr Greg
Sadler and today we're talking about
relationships pretty much
all the ways in which we conceive of
them and the obligations that we feel
and how Partners Place stresses upon
each other but also
provide you know the compliments the
sometimes we say life partner or the we
might even say the person who's intended
for us all of those sorts of things
we're going to be circling around today
yeah and it's going to be a little bit
of a grab bag here but I think it's a
very important topic that we are going
to try to dive into a little bit yeah
and as we were kicking the idea around
and thinking about how to title this
part of what we were were after was the
notion that when we're in a relationship
whether it's a good relationship or a
bad relationship there's there's always
more than just two partners who are say
in a contract or making demands on each
other it's not a purely mercenary
exchange there's something in the
relationship itself that comes to take
on a life of its own and it could be it
could be good or it could be bad or a
mixture of both depending on what people
are bringing to it and how they're
conceiving of it and whether they're on
the same page with what's going on
mm-hmm and you know I think if you're
looking at your relationship in a purely
like Market or transactional basis and I
think you're on a pretty you know uh
Rocky founder I guess uh Sandy
foundation for uh the basis of that
relationship yeah it's interesting that
you use that metaphor of the foundation
sand is no Foundation at all right this
is Descartes uses that idea in his uh
discourse on method and he says that all
these other philosophies and his his
time were based on on Sand and so you
know that's not bad until something
comes along to disturb things and then
suddenly your foundation is gone and he
wanted to build on on rock and I think
we could transpose that idea into
relationships so this is actually a
great place to start you mentioned
people having a sort of transactional
view of their relationships that you
know I give in order to to get why is
that a unsuitable foundation
um because you know I was looking up the
you know different types of uh economies
and it really brought me to this idea of
the the sharing economy because the the
dichotomy here is that I'm giving
something in a market economy that's
very transactional I'm giving something
of material value in order to gain
something of material value it's always
just like back and forth about what I
can give or I can get but in a an idea
of a uh sharing economy you have this
thing where you're giving out
on things in order to try to
build relationships here you're giving
it without the obligation of getting
something back you are getting uh you're
trying to uh hit that idea of
reciprocity but that idea of reciprocity
is the thing that builds those
relationships and you know you can have
a market economy as well uh with uh the
sharing economy but the sharing economy
is the thing that builds a relationship
on in and of itself
yeah I think that's that's completely
right to be able to make and we don't
necessarily have to use those terms to
be able to make a distinction between
two different modes of looking at things
and there are some relationships I think
in which it's perfectly appropriate for
us to have a very hard-nosed I I'm not
going to put stuff into this if I'm not
going to get stuff out like business
relationships right or when we're first
starting out in
um some sort of relationship with our
neighbors it you know it's nice to
invite people over and and cook them
some food or offer them some drinks but
if they don't reciprocate they're not
coming over very often after that right
if they if they never uh hold up their
end but there's you might say there's
certain thresholds within personal
relationships where if we if we do look
at it in a market sense however we want
to describe that perspective we're going
to cut ourselves off from possibilities
for growing and that relationship we're
going to make the other person at some
point in time feel like they're just
being used or valued only in terms of
what they're putting on the table you
know at that point for us and we're
going to screw things up it's not to say
that you know finances don't matter or
we shouldn't demand some sort of you
know some sort of reciprocity on the
part of our our partner that could be
measured but we we can't just be in that
and I think there's a lot of people who
do look at their relationships that way
or or there's relationships in which one
partner doesn't see it that way and the
other partner does see it that way and
those end up being bad relationships now
here's an interesting question are those
bad relationships for both of them or
are those bad relationships just for the
person who wants it to be something more
but not a bad relationship for the
person who wants to keep it purely
transactional what do you think
I think it's it's bad for both
um just because there's an a fundamental
mismatch of what the other is expecting
from it okay so
um you know both the person that wants a
transactional is put upon by the other
person that wants more as well as the
one that wants more is uh feeling like
they're on affections or whatever are
being rebuffed because the other person
doesn't want that it just you know you
want to have some sort of simpatico
equality into what you're expecting from
that relationship in the first place
yeah you know I was just reading
Cicero's uh on friendship this this book
that he wrote that's very relevant today
for producing some some lecture videos
from my classes on it and one of the
topics that he talks about is these
these ID these wrong-headed ideas about
friendships that were quite common back
in ancient times and one of them was
precisely this that you should only
exhibit Good Will which is benevolentia
in in Latin you should only exhibit
Goodwill to the degree that the other
person exhibits Goodwill so you should
kind of you know tailor it or or
um
what would you say measure it according
to that and Cicero says well this is a
terrible idea because it treats
friendship as if it's purely what we
would nowadays call transactional and
it's based on a it's sort of like a idea
that that everything is a zero-sum game
that if I give more I'm I'm getting
screwed or I'm getting cheated and I
can't you know get get back and and
Cicero says look at you know affection
is not like that it's not as if by
putting by giving more generously and he
uses this example of measures like
pouring uh grain into measures he says
listen if a little bit overflows that's
perfectly fine it's not going to go to
waste you know and if you're measuring
with a instead of like you know rounding
it off right at the top uh and and
making sure that it's like completely
even if you allow there to be a little
bit more on top that's going to be fine
and I think that when we don't do that
when we don't give a little bit more
than is is expected or required
over time that erodes the relationship
and and so a good relationship like
you're saying is part of a sharing
economy right
and so you brought up a zero-sum game
and it makes me think about uh you know
that mode of thinking within uh Game
Theory and the idea of like
relationships as positive some games and
that oh yeah that we are that you have
to explain a little bit I think all
right so like zero-sum game is like you
know we're playing uh chess or something
and there's there's only I guess three
outcomes you either I win and you lose
you win I lose or wear a stalemate but
there's no other way of doing that you
can't have both people win in a positive
sum game
um the the point is not to win but to
continue playing the game because
everyone benefits from playing the game
and so in a relationship having a
positive sum game is that the
relationship in and of itself is a good
that cannot that cannot be found outside
of that relationship
um and that uh you know if you look at
the whole host of like what it is to
have a good life or a udemonic life our
flourishing life you know a lot of them
require you to have good strong
relationships
um you know you look at Aristotle so you
have to have a good life they have to
have those good for good relationships
and I would rather have a life with lots
of good relationships than one Solitude
and by myself yeah that's a really good
point and you know in ancient philosophy
and also this this ran throughout
medieval and a lot of early modern
philosophy there is that realization
that without some kinds of good
relationships and they have different
ways of conceiving or defining them
our lives are are lacking and going back
to Cicero's on friendship which which is
taking off from Aristotle but going
going Beyond it he actually
um draws out this connection between
moral virtue or Excellence however we
want to to understand it you know good
character traits and friendship and he
says that even people who don't value
good character traits recognize that
they they want friendship they may not
enjoy it completely because they they
make themselves unable to be a good
friend but they can recognize that this
this is something that they would like
to have almost counter factually you
could say if they weren't the kind of
person who can't be a decent friend they
would want to have a friend and you know
you're right Aristotle
um says that it's not enough just to be
a good person to have good character we
also need to have relationships
Cicero goes even further and says
um maybe the the relationships
themselves are even more important than
moral virtue
which is an interesting idea and yeah I
don't think that he's pushing that
consistently throughout his Works
um but he and he is putting it in the
mouth of somebody else because it's a
dialogue so but but I I think that
really is an idea he's entertaining
there and and I think a lot of people do
that you know we don't have to be
completely perfect people in order to
have good sustaining relationships
whether they're friendships or you know
romantic Partnerships with a spouse or
boyfriend girlfriend whoever or even you
know a sort of like a a less intimate
level neighbors
um
you know people people like that and
then you know we've got all the
relationships within the family that we
might think about which are often quite
uh you know they change over time and
and there can often be quite difficult
think about sibling rivalry you know
right
and that that brings up the I think we
touched on this a little bit last week
but the whole point of either loyalty or
life doing what is right and you have to
like kind of choose which value you
value the most and
um and I feel like that's one of the
things about
uh relationships that it it because we
get so close especially to our spouses
that sometimes it gets really muddled
about at what point in time do you uh if
they've done something very very bad do
you like turn them in like you know
um if they like cheat on their taxes do
you like turn them in when it's your
friend or family probably not you know
but like you know they're murdered
somebody yeah yeah murders you know and
I brought up in our notes on you know
Macbeth and the story of Lady Macbeth
and Macbeth yeah and how she's goading
him in order to kill uh King Duncan
and and he does it because you know
that's that's his wife that's his
closest relationship and he seems to
value that more than anything else yeah
you know again uh bringing up Cicero an
awful lot of this book on friendship but
it's really quite good you know one of
the things that he talks about early on
are these demands of loyalty and whether
a good friend would ask us to do
something wrong and what we ought to do
when they when they do that and then
towards the end of the book he also
talks about how to criticize friends and
he tells us that this is actually a very
necessary thing and he's not being sort
of you know he's he's not saying we
should be passive aggressive about this
or you know look for opportunities to
criticize people he just thinks that
within the course of human relationships
being the kinds of not not entirely
finished products that we are morally
speaking we are going to screw up and we
need our friends he says not just to
warn us or to advise us the Latin term
for that it could mean either but also
to like tell us that we got things wrong
and then he gives some advice for how do
you do that you know and he says well
you need to avoid insult on the one hand
and you should also avoid harshness the
word that he uses there it could be
trans transliterated as asparity right
which which is kind of a a dryness or
harshness and you know he he really
thought that this was something that
people need to pay attention to and I
think he's completely right in our own
life you know if you're the kind of
person who can't take criticism in in
some ways you can't be a good friend or
a good lover or a good spouse because
you you're continually keeping people at
a distance that prevents not just you
know growth on your part which would be
good but also genuine intimacy but it
but it sucks to get criticized right
that's no fun
yeah I I absolutely agree that you know
for a actual good strong relationship
you should be very open
um with how you see the other person and
the a mark of I guess
personal development and a good
relationship is that you are able to
take those things without feeling like
you are being attacked what if you are
being attacked though what if what if
you have a partner who's not
fully developed in and is using it as an
opportunity to try to you know control
or dominate you or you know humiliate
you to make themselves feel good
uh but I think you have larger problems
than just yeah yeah and you know Cato it
gets gets oh no it was it's Scipio who
gets mentioned in there no it actually
is Cato I'm I'm going back and forth
oscillating between I assume the younger
correct yeah and Cato complained and
Cicero records this about people who
only learn the truth of themselves from
their enemies
who say how things actually are and and
criticize them on that basis in a spirit
of you know malice or ill will and they
don't learn who they are from their
friends because their friends are
unwilling to tell them the the things
about themselves that need to be
challenged or changed and he says these
people are really in a bad bad situation
because they're not going to listen to
their enemies they you know they hate
the enemies and they're the people who
should be helping them by gently
informing them of you know what they
need to change or what they need to at
least take a look at won't won't do it
for them so you know what what do you
think is there is there an obligation to
I don't think any of your friends should
be sycophants to just be yes men to your
ideas and and I actually had a personal
experience with this where I had a
friend who I was like I had to give some
like
blatant or not blatant but like blunt
um experience of like how I was
experiencing our relationship into some
of the things that he was doing within
it yeah and
um and he he responded in a very angry
way
um because I was I guess telling him the
way that I saw the things and I tried to
put in a kind way but I wasn't trying to
say you're you're doing perfectly fine
uh and
and at that point in time it really
became apparent that I needed to end
this relationship that this was the
person at least at this point in time is
not the person that I
um could have as a full confident and um
treat with the respect that I felt like
I should be giving a friend yeah you
know and that that points towards
another factor that is
identified early on in ancient
literature connected with with
friendship you know we feel affection or
desire towards people quite quickly but
that by itself isn't the basis for
friendship or a romantic relationship
you know we we it takes time to develop
Intimacy in a sense of where we can go
and where we can't go
um you know Aristotle has this proverb
that he takes from earlier authors about
needing to consume a barrel of salt
together now he doesn't mean like a
giant you know 50 gallon drum he means
he means like the sort of thing that
would sit on your your table uh and you
would sprinkle you know a bit of salt at
each meal and the idea is you need to
consume a lot of meals together in order
to to genuinely become
uh friends with each other in order to
get to know the person well because uh
we can we can often be mixed up about
about these sorts of things first first
appearances can be deceiving we can
generalize too much from single
instances and so I mean this is
something I think we'll we'll talk about
a little bit more this development of
of intimacy over time
yeah uh
first impressions are are very sticking
usually and I I guess I have definitely
used uh certain markers especially if
you know going out to
dinner and trying to oh yeah see how
they actually interact with the weight
staff because yeah that's a a pretty
good yardstick of kind of like okay how
does this person treat those people that
could be presented as lesser than them
or or they're in their power so to speak
right yeah
um I use that all the time in in my
ethics classes for my young students and
they like totally relate to it because
some of them have actually worked in
restaurants or they've worked you know
they've worked retail and they've
they've been in the the bad end of the
Stick of that sort of treatment and then
I always see like you know a couple kids
in the class get thoughtful and they're
and I I'm I'm picturing to myself that
maybe they're remembering instances
where somebody they know didn't treat
um service workers well you know or
maybe they're they're remembering their
own cases where they didn't and they're
they're now thinking oh man I need to
work on this sort of thing what's what's
going on with my my assumptions and how
I look at people right right
and so I don't know I'm gonna switch
tracks just a little bit and uh bring up
the idea that you shouldn't have a
partner or a relationship in order to
try to fix you oh yeah that's a really
good point
um that you don't need to be
um
a perfect uh person in perfect mental
health to have good relationships but
the idea is that you shouldn't be
Reliant upon that person to be the one
that is fixing you uh that you you
shouldn't be using your um your partner
as uh something to fill in your own
holes uh you should be there to
compliment that person and not
or the other yeah that's a that's a
that's a great point and I think a lot
of people get themselves into trouble
because we're we're you know we're kind
of driven by this lack within ourselves
and then we get all these cultural
messages that you know whether they come
from music or magazine spreads or uh
movies or pick whatever you like in our
popular culture that that portrays this
as Central to relationships you know
people oh you complete me you know uh
that that that whole line
um well you know the person might
complete you but the completed uh thing
might actually be a monstrosity you know
I mean maybe you you kind of belong
together because you're both messed up
but you you know sort of like uh imagine
like Legos that have been you know
warped by heat or something like that
they fit together but it's a terrible
composition and it won't fit in with
anything else so that's that's one thing
and then you know a lot of times people
they get into relationships and I know
I've had this experience myself
you're very excited at the beginning of
it you feel like the person is
completing you in some way and that
lasts for you know a month or two and
then suddenly you realize that uh
there's things about them that you know
you you really don't like and they may
be things about yourself that you also
don't like as well so it's not it's not
as as perfect as the honeymoon phase
portrayed it as being and I think
there's a lot of other problems with
this notion that we we want the other
person to like fill in all the gaps
within ourselves
[Music]
um
there's a lot to be said about that
yeah and you know related is this idea
that you shouldn't have your happiness
be dependent upon oh yeah you know your
your partner this is kind of no very
similar idea why why is that a bad idea
because then your happiness is outside
of your own control that you know you
your your mood will be contingent upon
you know potentially your your partner's
mood or something along those lines but
I mean if we want to play a devil's
advocate here shouldn't you shouldn't
you care about you know your
relationship with your partner and how
they feel and what's going on with them
shouldn't shouldn't that isn't that a
sign that they matter to you that that
affects you I don't think those two
things are in Conflict at all because no
you're right yeah but um because to put
it as a dichotomy and set it up like
that is is a false dichotomy I don't
um so uh uh I can care about you know my
my partner's happiness and whatnot but
if um if I can't be happy just because
my partner is Happy
um then I feel like that's a failing
upon yourself
you know it's interesting as you were
talking about that I was thinking about
like Partners who want their Partners to
they would say empathize with them or or
commiserate with them but they really
want their Partners to be angry with
them at the same people they come home
and they talk about how their boss is a
jerk and their co-workers are lawful and
you know the bus ride or whatever it's
going to be and the right response is
yeah those sobs who were they to do that
to you right that's not actually a good
Dynamic though and you know I was also
thinking too Aristotle in discussing
friendship and I think this applies to
other relationships as well he says that
one of the key traits of it is that we
share in the other person's Joys and we
share in their their sorrows and he uses
those two emotional modalities and I
think there's probably something to that
you know if if you so like if if I tell
you that which I I will be doing
eventually that that one of my pets has
has died and I'm really sad about it and
you don't and you're just like well you
know death comes to us all you know I'm
not going to view you as as sharing in
my sorrow obviously I don't want you
like tearing your beard out and you know
render renting renting renting your
clothes like they did in the evening
mashing my teeth exactly that would be
that would be crazy and excessive and
actually a little scary but
um you know we expect there to be some
sort of reaction so is there is there
um
how do you know what are the the right
sorts of
empathizing or
even sympathizing in the sense of of
feeling the same thing without without
falling into what some of the
philosophers call emotional contagion
you know you get angry at I don't know
some some perceived offense and I'm like
oh I can't believe they did that to Dan
you know
and now I'm just as angry as you are
obviously we don't we don't want that is
there is there a line we can draw well I
think the first good line is to be very
very cautious of anger and being a
contagious anger yeah because that's
that's going to lead you to uh
potentially very negative outcomes that
are not actually in the benefit of
anyone
um and you know I I also have that
experience of like you know your partner
wanting
you know coming home and just venting
and and like always being angry about
like the same things over and over and
wanting you to be angry and I just said
puts me into a very negative headspace
where I want to commiserate with this
person
but also
um noticing that it has a a visceral
effect on my personal my personal
experience my emotional state and I
would rather not have and in a way it
puts you in a bad position as far as
um
the assumptions you have to make right
so let's say two different partners
right we have one who comes home and
they're legitimately angry about how
their boss treated them at work and
their boss really did do the wrong
things I think it would make sense to
feel some anger although not you know
like I'm gonna you know trash the
apartment kind of kind of thing uh about
that because you you
um you see that there's a legitimate
beef there and then maybe you're like
well you know it doesn't actually help
to get angry in this case let's sort of
sit down and figure out what we can do
you know maybe you need a new boss
meaning you need a new workplace and
then there's the one who comes in and
they are angry about things but the
stuff that they're angry about is
unreasonable they took offense when they
didn't need to take offense and they
blew things out of proportion and if
you're supposed to like go down their
path that means that you have to take on
mistaken assumptions and sort of it's
almost like you have to do like a
you have to overcome the cognitive
dissonance of saying to yourself This is
unreasonable uh in order to be able to
say I I totally agree with you and then
you know you're worse off in part not
just because you're angry but because
you're you're angry about stuff that
doesn't matter that stuff that isn't
true you you you disalign yourself with
the true the right the good in order to
fit in better with your partner and you
know you could say well maybe that's the
value there right being in alignment
with somebody who you love and care
about and want to spend time with but if
they're that out of whack with reality
they're going to keep getting you more
and more out of whack with reality and
that's not going to be good for either
one of you right
right
one of the
texts that I've found to be very useful
are these situations is to ask what do
you want in this situation do you do you
want to have to vent and have a little
catharsis or um
or do you want me to help you solve this
problem
um or do you want me to bust up the
place
[Laughter]
um and
and a lot of times the the what your
partner just needs is to to vent but
then it gets to the point of kind of a
what is it a
Chicken Little problem or the boy who
cried wolf where okay yeah if it's the
same thing over and over and over then
you become start to become numb to this
thing and then when something actually
of consequent happens then you have been
conditioned to say okay yeah it's just a
thing yeah I feel bad for you as well
and and you know gir to them
but but now you're you are have a
mismatch between the the actual
necessary things that might need to be
done versus uh what you are actually
expressing to your partner yeah
what do you think about some of the
other emotions so I mentioned Aristotle
said we should share in the joys and
share in the the Sorrows or sadnesses
should we share in the sadness of things
with our our partners maybe not you know
not in every case like if they are
seriously depressed that doesn't mean
that in order to love them we have to
become seriously depressed as well but
you know uh something something bad does
happen or they they're looking around at
the situation that we're in and they
they feel down about that
um is there some is there some value in
Sharing in that with them you know it's
a negative emotion right
um I think
especially in order to deal with grief
you know oh yeah that's that's what that
yeah should we distinguish between like
being down and and grieving where grief
is due to loss
um
sure yeah especially when we're just
talking about you know General malaise
yeah you know and uh maybe uh minor
depression or something along those
lines you know definitely want to maybe
Comfort them but to to share in
someone's depression is not probably
productive for anyone uh but especially
within you know grief you've got a loss
that is a a one-time event usually and
then but that is is something usually
very emotionally uh jarring that you
know we have these you know strong
connections to these people and I
absolutely think that relationships are
um
uh a very good way to
deal with these types of of loss and and
I I absolutely agree with
Aristotle there you know if you want to
go to other emotions like jealousy or
greed or uh Envy Envy yeah yeah uh then
I think that's probably not going to be
a good thing to share in yeah yeah we
could I mean we could talk about
uh other malice right the lighting in
somebody else
feeling feeling pain
um maybe there's there's or or yeah
there's there's quite a few negative
emotions that we wouldn't want to take
on and you do see people in
relationships kind of urging each other
with those right kind of amplifying that
almost like a feedback loop
I wonder how that feels within a
military
context especially if you're in active
combat and you're you're sharing in I
guess the Delight of victory over an
enemy but it's also the the little bit
of that shot and void of that like
having happiness at the disfortion of
others
yeah although usually it's those others
who are trying to shoot at you so you've
got a pre-text for
um you know wanting them injured or dead
or taken off the field or something like
that I I would also I mean the military
thing brings up like fear as well
sometimes raw Terror you know
that I guess a uh shared courage would
be something that I would promote
yeah
um and there we're talking more about a
disposition than just just an emotion
right but if you look at courage as like
uh fortitude in the face of fear yeah
feeling feeling a kind of confidence
um the capacity to handle things yeah I
mean that could be certainly Amplified
you know that's actually a good point
there there are quite a few things that
we need other people to be
working with us on
so thinking about a military unit right
if you're if you're like super soldier
you know whoever I'll call him GI Joe
and uh you're the most you know uh
accomplished military person
Omega infantry you know but but you've
got you know the capacity to carry all
sorts of heavy weapons as well just like
in video games right which are totally
unrealistic when it comes to to this
sort of stuff
um you know we we portray that person as
if he's able or she's able to operate
entirely on their own but that isn't the
way anything actually works in in the
military you're constantly dependent on
a whole train of people resupplying you
and the people next to you and if
they're screw-ups you know I actually so
I'll tell you kind of an interesting
story that that brings to mind I was I
was in the Army and I got I went in an
89 uh not that long before the the Wall
came down and we like totally had to
change our what we were going to do
because Warsaw Pact fell apart and the
Soviet Union was falling apart and
that's what we were primed to do in
Germany that's what we were training for
and I was a combat engineer which means
that I did infantry stuff and I also did
demolitions and set up barriers and
minefields and all sorts of really fun
things to do
and there were people in our unit and we
we used to call them the cheesers and
and you know there's all sorts of names
for these sorts of people these are the
guys who really didn't know their jobs
very well and they were kind of jerks
but they were really obsessed with like
keeping their uniform pressed and their
boots you know shined up and it sort of
you know they were like great picture
soldiers
um and they would always you know kind
of kiss the rear ends of whoever was in
charge but they they weren't very good
soldiers and then we'd have all sorts of
you know other people a lot of these
were our ncos who are kind of grizzled
and you know didn't keep themselves up
all that well and there was at that time
Unfortunately they were they were
enjoying the dividends of Peace by
getting rid of a lot of people and they
you know they were getting rid of um
people who were really good
non-commissioned officers and writing
them up over stupid things like you know
not having their boots shined at the
proper time they would create a paper
trail and then they'd kick them out so
they couldn't so they couldn't collect a
pension some of them with 17 years of
service in
shortly after that and they were then
they were just like kicking people out
like crazy and I actually took the early
out because I I didn't I didn't want to
be in in our unit anymore
um seeing what was going on
shortly after that Desert Shield started
now nobody could get out and a lot of
the good people who you would want to go
into combat with had been phased out and
a lot of the people who were you know
Wonderful uh uh you might call them
guard house soldiers but we're not
particularly good soldiers they were in
and they were the ones who got Rank and
and you think to yourself okay if you're
a competent engineer and you're in Iraq
and they've got minefields and the mines
are not just regular conventional mines
but chemical mines if one guy screws up
that's going to screw up the whole Squad
right it's potential and unfortunately
this didn't happen that way but we were
thinking about these things you actually
you you want to have people lined up
with you who are good at what they do
and are properly disposed morally
speaking you can't function by yourself
doing really good things without a Nexus
of relationships of other decent people
and we can transpose this into business
settings we can talk about you know for
example our organization the the
Milwaukee stoic Fellowship which I think
is a pretty good organization we have
people who are like doing things
including yourself right you created
this the walk and talks and continue
that right
um I'm really happy because then I don't
I don't have to like do much leadership
stuff anymore you know the idea was to
Facebook to other people and and you
want that sort of thing and in a
relationship obviously you're not gonna
like you know Outsource your
relationship duties in a relationship
that would be that'd be nonsense but you
you do need to have a partner who isn't
just depending on on you to be the sole
um
provider the the sole person who's who's
contributing good things to it you know
the sole support and likewise you don't
want to be the the needy one in that
sense you you got to like you know
you don't have to necessarily do
everything but you have to be able to do
some things competently in your
relationship right so that so that we're
not just codependent to use the
psychological term and this comes back
to sort of that one thing that you
started with like needing the other
person to be the complement of yourself
right and the compliment could be two
things it could be like well we do fill
in the the the areas where even though
we're striving really hard and doing
everything we need to do
um we're still falling short and then
there's the like I'm a lazy person who's
got huge holes in what I can do and I go
to this other person to like make me
whole one one is good and one is bad
right
uh the idea that you should feel good
help in your partner but you shouldn't
be dependent upon it that you'll look at
as the the cherry on top of your Sunday
that oh yeah yeah
um uh well-being within your own life
um and that you you shouldn't be
dependent upon your partner to make sure
that you have you know some semblance of
well-being
yeah I mean there could be cases where
like okay you get really sick oh yeah or
um something else happens you know
you're you're you brought up depression
you're disabled by depression and grief
for for a while while your partner is
there to help support you then right
right and and you you hope that that
person is there for you and vice versa
in the future yeah
um
I guess
what I'm thinking like is not you know
uh physical Melodies but like you're
um your emotional well-being that what
you find to be uh
a flourishing life or a well-being
within your life especially in the
psychological sense yeah that makes good
sense yeah this is also not not
including you know uh clinical
depression and whatnot these are outside
of the scope of what I'm thinking here
yeah and and if you think about the the
sources of tensions within relationships
that that break things down
um
very often they have to do not just you
know there's there's the finances
there's sex there's whether or not like
in a romantic relationship you want to
have children but I think a lot of a lot
of the tensions that arise within a
relationship have to do with
um who's giving who attention and
um you know the the nature of the
relationship whether the relationship is
itself being valued or whether
um people are taking advantage of each
other
yeah
so uh I think we need to switch gears
here and talk about um our question of
the week yeah and this is actually a
good segue because you know it's about
finances right yeah so I guess the main
topic is am I the jerk for making more
money than my so do you want to expand
on that Greg sure so we you know we like
to look around on on some of the Reddit
forums for these interesting questions
that come up and there there is one
there and it's not actually called am I
the jerk we're using that as a euphemism
because we're not going to say the word
on the air but you know what Forum it is
and it's by a uh woman in her 30s who
was working a bad job and she wound up
um because of this this crisis that
we're in she says I was recently
informed after work additional overtime
to help with the influx of loans
provided by the government to top it off
I got a Bonus recently on top of my
raise plus the overtime and the stimulus
checks means I have more money in my
pocket than I have had in the last two
years I was really struggling before all
this happened and had to do things on
the side just to get by
my partner recently got his hours cut at
his job and were not certain if he will
have a job at the end of the month prior
to this he was having a lot of financial
trouble and then she she goes a little
bit skipping down she says
um
when I got the news I would be working
overtime my boyfriend got upset with me
that I was being insensitive to him
about how good I have it now and that I
have all this money I feel really alone
here in not being able to share my good
news with anyone and I thought he would
be happy for me considering how severely
unhappy I was to prior to getting this
position but the joy literally got
sucked out of me and I can't even buy
something nice for myself without
seeming like I'm an insensitive jerk so
then she asked am I am I the jerk and I
I think the answer is definitely no what
do you think Dan
um I am in complete agreement
and
and I think this is really comes down to
what the on her partner has as a
preconceived conception of what his role
in that relationship is and especially
within the Western World in the United
States
um there's been studies that say that
once a
um a woman in a relationship makes about
40 of the total income of a
um a partner's gross income that that's
a time where it starts to become a
problem for the man because there's a
preconceived notion that the man is the
one that's supposed to make the money to
bring home the bread and there's a
cognitive disconnect that he's having
between what he expects and what his
reality is and he might not even be
aware of that
yeah and I think we have to take those
those findings with you know some some
grain of salt right because uh obviously
it changes I think I think
generationally that that changes a bit
like uh you know if we're looking at
younger people now maybe those numbers
would be a little bit
um lower than say baby boomers but there
there definitely can be a lot of rancor
about these sorts of issues and I
actually see a larger issue here which
is one partner
suddenly doing well in some area
and the other partner feeling like
they're not they're not getting to
participate in that in in some way right
it makes them feel bad so like it could
be I'll give you an example that could
could apply to to my life so
um my my own wife in in many respects is
way more accomplished than I am when it
comes to uh connections within all sorts
of different intellectual and practical
spheres
um and you know I you know my my
response is isn't oh well now I'm
somehow less because she has become you
know pointed to this board or you know
president of this or involved in this
really cool project or anything like
that it's rather to say oh that's really
great you know now it could also be oh
that's really great because now I don't
have to do anything myself and I can
just like you know hang on her coattails
I don't have that reaction either that
would be another thing but I think and
and we we do want to you know we don't
want to say that that's good good right
um you know Aristotle in interestingly
Aristotle talks about a passion that he
calls emulation which is the translation
of the Greek zelos that we get the word
zeal from and when you're when you're
feeling emulation it's not the same
thing as feeling Envy when you're
envious you want the other person to
fail so that you don't feel bad about
you know your own lack of success
emulation is when you see somebody who
actually deserves to to be recognized
for what they're doing
um getting honored or something like
that and you're like oh man I wish that
was me but I wish I actually deserved
that like so when I see like a colleague
write a really good book
one of my reactions is that that feeling
and it's not envy I don't you know I'm
like oh man I wish I could have written
that book but I can't because you know
that's not my area of specialization and
they're the person to have written the
book so good for them right that's
that's actually a good response but but
it seems like her boyfriend has the
opposite response you know
is taking away from him in some way yeah
I think he's looking at this uh to a
certain extent like a competition yeah
that's very um there's there's a winner
and a loser in this particular thing and
you know it kind of goes back to our
talking about games very earlier the
idea of a zero-sum game versus a
positive sum game and that you know uh
your partner's benefit should be your
benefit and it doesn't mean that there's
anything taken away from you yeah so
actually if we want to use that we could
say there's the zero-sum game mentality
on one side at one extreme and and
there's the well that's great that
you're succeeding I'm going to be a
parasite mentality on the other side
right at another extreme and then
there's some something healthy in the
middle
and and I like the idea of the emulation
that there's you know uh I would call a
healthy relationship one that uh each
partner is happy for their the other's
success as well as uses that as maybe
motivation to
um increase their own success however
they want to Define that yeah you know
and there's again this goes back to a
great uh topic discussed in Aristotle's
Nick and McCain ethics
um he in in book nine when he's
discussing friendship he talks about
um competition
and whether it's okay to be self-loving
fill out toast in Greek and he says that
a lot of people say that if you're if
you're self-loving or selfish that
you're a bad person because of that he
says well no it depends on the kinds of
things that it has to do with so if it's
if it's things that really are kind of a
zero-sum game like money or honor or
attention if I get more of it you get
less of it so if I desire to have more
than my fair share I'm depriving you
right so I shouldn't be selfish in that
respect but when it comes to other
things that can be shared and if I
possess I'm not taking away from you
like moral virtue or wisdom or really
any of the things that are that are core
to who we are
um the fact that I do well by becoming
courageous doesn't mean you become less
courageous as a result as if it's
someone like flows out of you and into
me right instead you can that can help
you be more courageous and if I share
the knowledge that I have with you I
it's not like it goes out of my head
into your head like we're copying files
or something right or actually rather
moving files instead we we replicate
something in somebody else and so he
says we should be in competition with
each other to who can be the most
virtuous and if we do that it's not
going to hurt anybody because we're
going to be doing good things and I
think that makes really good sense
within a relationship
it doesn't mean that both Partners have
to like try to outdo each other and who
can make the most money that's that's
that's probably not going to be helpful
but yeah then you're just participating
in avarice yeah exactly yeah
um yeah and
and I think we might want to move to
practice here or yeah we still have more
to talk about no I think that that wraps
that up pretty well
so we've got a practice here which is
um speak without judging which seems to
be a very useful School skill to have
with your own partner and
um so you should Reserve or the practice
is to reserve Judgment of things for you
do not have all the information about
why they are doing it doubly so speak
without judgment to your partner
so what what would it be what would be
an example of speaking without judgment
to your partner a common case that we
would run across
um a lot of times it's just uh try to
avoid using the words like good or bad
and try to okay
um speak in in the objective term So
like
um you know uh calling
um someone that that
um drinks too much I guess you could say
um he drinks too much instead of he
drinks poorly or he's he's a drunk
because then you are adding the
emotional stigma of that is a negative
thing and it might actually come to a
negative outcomes but
um in order to actually help that person
move forward they don't want to be
labeled with the uh the label of bad but
yeah it is now which is something that
is a an adjective to describe the person
and more to the point of uh describing
the particular action and the actions
are a lot easier to change than a
Badness or goodness of a person so
there's two good sides to this right
there's the side of yourself which is
that you're not by not labeling them
you're not going down all those trains
of thought where you have to say well
why am I even with this kind of person
um you know or I should do something to
retaliate against this person or I need
to be on guard against this this person
who's always this way people do often
use always never language when it comes
to these these sorts of things and then
like you said when you're actually
dealing with your partner
you can
preclude pushing their buttons right
doing things that are going to keep them
from hearing what you're genuinely
bothered by and would like to see
getting getting fixed in some way
so another example this would be like
say
um your partner has just come back from
a workout or a run or something and now
they've been sweating and they they have
a rank smell to them
laughs
and
um you know you say like oh you know
you're you you bathe poorly no they just
you didn't you maybe uh you weren't
aware that they had just come back from
some sort of workout and so all of a
sudden the the initial oppression that
you're getting is just that they smell
bad and you can either say uh you uh Hey
at this point in time you might need to
uh bathe but not to say that you bathed
poorly is or that you just have poor
personal hygiene right that's how we
would probably say it today you know
yeah
yeah that that's actually a a really
good example because of what it points
to is in many cases going along with
this maybe what we need to do is get
more information
you know if if um like we don't know
that the person just got back from
working out
um they just they just come in and
um
they uh plop themselves down on the
couch and we don't know that they're
planning on taking a shower in half an
hour or something like that if we ask
them questions we can find out oh
um you you actually are going to deal
with this and there's so many other
relationship things I think where people
are quite worried that their partner
isn't going to take this thing seriously
or is going to act this way all the time
not realizing that it's it's a unusual
situation you know
yeah it kind of plays into the um the
fundamental attribution air bias well
say something about that because that's
not a term everyone's going to know
absolutely and so the fundamental
attribution error is the idea that you
um
have in your mind that
um you have made decisions based on
certain circumstances but you are more
predisposed to me the idea that other
people's decisions are based on their
character oh and so that yeah
and so this you know
the the your partner works out they're
going to take a shower in a half hour on
and so you think like oh you know he's
just a slob whereas he's like yeah but I
had to do this thing before you know I
have a timeline I have to do this and in
expecting to do that in a moment whereas
your your partner might be thinking like
oh he's just a slob and that is his
character and now I have to like
reassess do I actually want to be in a
relationship with a person that's a slob
yeah or do I want to like go after them
and criticize them for their slavishness
now here's a question what do we do
about people who genuinely are
you know they do have bad habits they
they you know like let's take the the
example we were talking about before the
person who wants you to always be their
Ally and being angry against other
people I know I I had a previous
relationship like this and it ended when
I when I quit doing that within a week
of saying you know these people aren't
as bad as we make them out to be the
relationship was finished
because she wasn't getting out of it
what she she wanted what what what
should we do when we've got Partners who
maybe they're they're good in other ways
but there are genuinely problematic
aspects of their their personality or
their character what would you say
well as we spoke about earlier it's the
uh the ability to have a good
relationship is uh to a certain extent
depending upon their ability to not be a
sycophant to not always be in the Yes
man that agrees with them and to give
them some blunt advice
um at least in the way that you see that
and if they can't
um take that advice it makes it really
difficult to have a relationship in that
regard yeah so there's kind of a you
know there's no like hard and fast rules
for this this is where Prudence would
come in right
yeah
um and it's going to be different for
every person and everyone's on a journey
of their own life and trying to become a
better person hopefully do you think
it's helpful to have other people
involved in the situation giving advice
giving counsel or you know because of
the intimacy of a relationship the fact
that people are looking in only through
really limited Windows is it better to
like keep them keep them out
I I think if you don't have that ability
to be candid then there's uh
a aspect one relationship that I feel
that you could definitely improve upon
yeah that's you know that may be
actually a great topic to pick up next
time I see we're getting close to the
end of our our hour any last thoughts
uh
hopefully I I wish everyone good health
within their relationship and uh
what not you well I had to do this
really nice line by rilka Rayner Maria
rilka who talks about genuine love as
being
two solitudes protecting and bordering
and greeting each other and I think
that's like it's it's the epitome of
what we're talking about here provided
we understand what he means by solitude
thank you Greg and we leave you today
with the words of Maya Angelou if you
don't like something change it if you
can't change it change your attitude
[Music]
thank you